[Musique]
certains fermiers achètent leurs graines
des grandes compagnies chaque année pour
les planter moi je garde les miennes
c'est comme ça que je travaille je
conserve mes craque le premier canal là
qu'il arrive cette année c'est
l'agresseur
est ce que tu en dis combien ça t'a
coûté tout ça est un investissement un
colis pour monsieur heure-ci schmeiser
là bas il doit y avoir une erreur
j'ai mes propres graines
monsanto prétend que le canola que vous
avez cultivées en 97 présenter une
modification génétique créé par monsanto
ils sont déjà passés c'est qui ces gens
tapis monsanto va soutenir que toutes
ces graines sont sa propriété et bien le
tribunal tranchera
monsieur schmeiser avez vous déjà acheté
le canola de monsanto non monsieur
mazères rebecca salle co2 citoyens pour
la protection de l'environnement il ya
des milliers de personnes qui veulent
vous soutenir notre message circule ils
disent que j'ai cultivé le canola de
monsanto sans acheter la licence tout
montre après le labeur de toute ma vie
leur appartient c'est moi qu'on pense me
pour avoir fait ce que ma famille a
toujours fait depuis des centaines
d'années c'est la une du washington post
est formidable un million deux cent
mille dollars c'est la somme que voleur
voilà ce qui se passe quand on a recours
aux avocats nous allons perdre la ferme
pour tenter de cette propriété derrière
l'affairé silver on n'a pas besoin
qu'ils gagnent on a juste besoin qu'ils
continuent de se battre c'est à dire de
faire appel à la cour suprême
c'est ce que vos avocats vous ont
conseillé je n'ai pas encore prévenu
pourquoi avoir porté deux proposent
jusqu'au plus haut tribunal le boko
fermiers dans le nord n'ont pas les
moyens de se battre j'ai pensé que je
devais faire il s'agit d'une simple
affaire de violation si vous gagnez plus
haut qu'un fermier ne pourra être
poursuivi pour avoir conservé ses
graines ce qu'il faut est témoin et on
ne peut pas les laisser faire il fallait
se battre
[Musique]